and they start with a horrible snap and
the
browns one with a touchdown we're not
just a bunch of grey faces anymore who
can't win a playoff game
[Applause]
welcome to the playoffs baby hey these
games made for everybody's game for the
elite
just give them all you got today in
buffalo it's the 11-5 colts and the 13-3
bills in the afc
wildcard game one of the big stories
today the return
of the bills fans 6 700 of them anyway
oh i can play catcher's demand let's go
buffalo
let's go buffalo hey one job let's win
we're not getting one it's the 12 and
four seahawks hosting
the 10 and six los angeles rams on
super wild card weekend beautiful day to
play ball
you all ready for the show time let's be
great let's be great
let's go get it tough come on
championship mindset championship
mindset one point in time let's go
dominate the goat tom brady will make
his 43rd appearance
in a playoff game let's go bro let's
have a good day man i believe in you bro
taylor heineke comes in here it is a
huge
huge task ahead of him hey we
representing from a man
ravens get set to take on the tennessee
titans there's a rematch from last
year's playoff loss
[Applause]
let's go come on come on i
ain't ready to go home i need nothing to
be saved
this is your chapter this is us right
now nothing else in the past matters
but this moment all right everybody we
got there playing out football today
miss here's the kind of games you play
for winner go home really think drew
brees
knows this is one of the best shots to
win a super bowl let's go baby
here hey play inspired play inspired for
everything we've been through together
this year win on three one two three
man you know what time it is play out
football in pittsburgh
prime time it doesn't get no better man
i've been waiting 18
long years for this let's go bro
whatever you got tonight i gotta have it
i need it all
right now we know tomorrow it
start 18 years since our last playoffs a
defensive touchdown
off a fumble i'm not getting off the
treadmill for the rest of my life
[Applause]
josh keeps it he's gonna try to run with
it and now he's gonna throw it into the
end zone and he's caught touchdown
[Music]
[Applause]
another turnover
important for us to keep our foot on the
gas now we just do our job each and
every place
here comes hunt he's going to get to the
five and he's going in touchdown
the bronze lead 28 nothing in the first
quarter let's go hey you about to go off
go buddy
can't wait to see it let's go come on
the late blitz are coming rust
got to get rid of it look out now he's
going to throw
the catch holy catfish a perfect deep
strike
let's keep playing good job man great
job great job right there that's a good
start
you got to go to school collapsing
on a magnificent scramble and dash for
the end zone
that's right that's what we're talking
about that's what we're talking about
easy
money let's go easy money yeah
yeah yeah well i'm gonna beat him on
that choice
because i'm gonna take it and
[Applause]
josh firing deep down near the end zone
looking for things he's got it
he's running to the left side to the
five diving for the end zone
[Music]
[Applause]
hey let's crank it up great temple now
one plate of time get open for me if you
can
looking for someone to throw to under
pressure he dumps it underneath
latavius murray at the five across the
goal line touchdown
hey
[Applause]
[Applause]
and t-shirts to cabo the seahawks lost
to the rams
round one tragic
absolutely tragic two seconds to go
mitch to throw
up in the hall jimmy graham
wow breeze is he's just taking a right
in
all right hey man thanks good luck yes
i'll see you this off season right yeah
big drive boys come on big driver
bro
[Applause]
hey knock you down four seconds left
they get one play to make it
rivers going for all of it down the
right sideline the pass up in the air
it is duck down and complete
the bill's winning in the last second
the bells win it
what a finish unbelievable finish
that's one baby
[Applause]
doesn't change what we got to do let's
go good do whatever you got to do to
keep getting first downs
marcus peters drops into coverage
tannehill steps and fires and is
intercepted
[Applause]
they're out there stomping on the logo
i'm off to the store because i need ice
cream
who can't win a playoff game oh
who can't win one
touch down or uh take away y'all put
them away i thought they're gonna go to
the fourth quarter the bronx lead by 12.
screen pass right side here comes chuck
he's going he's going
[Applause]
oh i feel worse for you than me i hate
it man we're the same old browsers
you can take time all the way to fishing
buddy
you can fish all night long we'll see
you next week
in kansas city
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]